[Musica]
dieci anni fa ho preso la decisione più
importante della mia vita
dieci anni fa caterina una giovane donna
brillante della mia azienda viene nel
mio ufficio sono responsabile del
personale e mi dice molto nervosa sono
incinta sono felice di diventare mamma
però non so cosa succederà di me quando
rientro dal congedo
ho sentito come un colpo allo stomaco
come se mi avessero tirato un pugno e ho
cercato di ricordarmi quando avevo
provato quella sesta sensazione nel
passato mi sono ricordata degli anni
della scuola ero orgogliosa dei miei bei
voti perché mi sarei fatta avanti nel
mondo del lavoro
ero la prima laureata della mia famiglia
mi sentivo potente e privilegiata poi ho
iniziato a lavorare è un giorno il mio
capo viene da me e mi dice con grande
naturalezza ma sonia non puoi avere una
famiglia e una carriera se decidi di
fare un figlio devi fare un passo
indietro
ecco in quel momento provato lo stesso
pugno nello stomaco che provo adesso
davanti a caterina che è incinta e non
sa se tornerà al lavoro
quel pugno allo stomaco si è trasformato
in una rabbia in un moto di ribellione
mi sono detta che cosa posso fare io per
caterina dalle mie nella mia posizione e
soprattutto la maternità dovrebbe essere
un evento naturale e allora mi sono
ricordata del mio congedo maternità di
quando sono rientrata dal congedo nel
mondo del lavoro
mi sembrava di rincorrere a piedi un
treno che passava tutta velocità un
treno guidato da un conducente che non
voleva vedermi e non fermava il treno
neanche lo rallentava io però ce l'ho
fatta sono salita mi sono aggrappata
quel treno e ce l'ho fatta
ma quale prezzo ne porto ancora oggi le
cicatrici
quindi mi sono detta nella mia posizione
solo una responsabile del personale
posso fare qualcosa per le mamme che
rientrano dal congedo lo devo fare sennò
chi lo fa
e quindi ho pensato ho intervistato
mamme o ho sentito i loro problemi quali
erano le loro difficoltà e alla fine ho
pensato quattro semplici regole che
avrei applicato da domani nella mia
azienda prive di prima di tutto prima
regola ascoltare le mamme al rientro le
avrei ascoltate una una capendo cercando
di capire quando erano difficoltà quali
erano i limiti che cosa potevo fare io
per loro ma soprattutto dicendo al
ognuna di loro che la maternità è un
valore anche per l'azienda e che loro
possono essere loro stesse
secondo avrei ascoltato anche il papa
anche i papà hanno un ruolo nella
crescita dei figli anche loro non vanno
scherzati se chiedono un congedo
bisogna creare attorno una cultura
favorevole e soprattutto dargli dei
giorni di paternità di congedo
retribuiti
terzo la fiducia uomini donne possono
lavorare autonomamente responsabilmente
e così non devono mancare ai momenti
importanti della vita della famiglia
come l'inserimento al nido o la recita
scuola iv
parliamo di soldi avrei fatto di tutto
per sostenere il salario delle mamme
durante il congedo e soprattutto nella
mia azienda
una volta rientrate non sarebbero state
messe in un angolo ma sarebbero state
loro stesse considerate per un aumento
di merito una promozione come tutti gli
altri
così molto sicura di me stessa arrivo
nella sala riunione dovevo presentare
davanti a tutti i miei capi uomini e
naturalmente avrei messo in relazione
questi comportamenti con i risultati
aziendali
ero convinta presento finisco la
presentazione silenzio nella sala
riunione non vola neanche una mosca i
miei capi non sapevano cosa mi
rispondermi primo non portavo nessuna
metrica e nessun numero supporto di
queste misure secondo nessuno aveva mai
messo in relazione queste misure con i
risultati aziendali ma soprattutto terzo
non avevano mai rincorso un treno che
passa a tutta
cita però io ho deciso di non arrendermi
ho deciso di insistere e almeno di farmi
fare una prova e alla fine hanno detto
di sì
ancora oggi penso che li ho presi per
sfinimento e così applico la policy
queste quattro regole a ogni mamma che
rientra dal congedo maternità a una
mamma due mamme tre mamme quattro mamme
a un numero sempre maggiore e
soprattutto osservo ogni mamma rientro
dal congedo è più preparata più
produttiva più creativa più organizzata
più brava e allora incontro dei
ricercatori che hanno avuto la mia
stessa intuizione misurano in maniera
scientifica le competenze della mamma
prima e dopo il congedo maternità e li
chiamo in azienda per misurare le
competenze delle mie mamme sapete che
cosa scopriamo dei risultati
straordinari
sapete quanto aumenta la competenza di
una mamma nel prendere decisioni prima e
dopo il congedo più 20 per cento
e quanto aumenta la sua capacità di
organizzare il suo tempo più 30 per
cento
e quanto aumenta la capacità di delegare
sul lavoro più 35 per cento sono dati
straordinari e potrei continuare con
l'elenco perché vedete in questi dieci
anni di osservazione
posso dire che ogni esperienza di cura
che sia fatta da un uomo da una donna
aumenta grandemente le competenze in
qualsiasi ruolo funzione e quindi la
cura è un grandissimo valore anche per
il mondo economico ma non basta in dieci
anni di applicazione feroce di queste
quattro regole quando dico feroce voglio
dire feroce perché sono state difese
ogni giorno i risultati sono
straordinari e mi emoziona ogni volta
che li misura prima di tutto l'ingaggio
delle persone che vuol dire la
motivazione la felicità delle persone è
al massimo livello e questo fa capire
che le persone tendendo una mano danno
il massimo
secondo il tasso di natalità nella mia
azienda è positivo vuol dire che nascono
più bambini
come quando eleonora mi dice non ho
avuto il coraggio di fare il terzo
figlio perché sapevo che l'azienda mira
vicina
terzo un manager su due donna questo
cosa vuol dire vuol dire che pesa la
mano e aiutata la mamma a rientrare nel
mondo del lavoro questa da se lo vuole
il massimo come quando noi abbiamo
affidato il progetto più strategico
dell'azienda a una mamma che rientrava
dal secondo congedo maternità
indovinate è stato un successo quarto lo
stesso salario per uomini e donne
che cosa significa significa non
penalizzare la mamma perché la donna
perché mamma potenzialmente e quinto
l'ultima grandissima risultato tutte le
mamme rientrano dal congedo vuol dire
che quella mano tesa ha permesso loro di
non arrendersi e di rientrare se lo
vogliono e questo è un grandissimo
risultato
e allora mi chiedo che cosa succederebbe
se noi applicassimo queste quattro
semplici regole alle 400mila donne che
ho in italia diventano mamme ogni anno o
alle 41 milioni di donne che ogni anno
diventano mamme nel mondo pensate a
quale e quanta energia si sprigionerebbe
nel mondo e questo è perché la cura non
arricchisce solamente chi vive questa
esperienza ma l'azienda il paese il
sistema economico dove la persona si
inserisce e quindi arrivato il momento
di tendere una mano alle donne per far
crescere il nostro paese e per far
crescere il mondo è arrivato il tempo di
agire e arrivato il tempo di misurare i
risultati della nostra azione di essere
orgogliosi dei numeri che misureremo e
soprattutto di lasciare ai nostri figli
un mondo più potente e più giusto
andando oltre
grazie
[Applauso]